what I want to explore in this video is
the different ways of measuring the
amount of money we have in circulation
so we're going to start things with our
central bank in the US this would be the
US Federal Reserve and let's say that
they print let's say that they print $4
and we're going to focus just for
visualization purposes on that they're
doing it physically they could also do
it electronically but we're just going
to focus on the physical and the way
that they get this into circulation is
that they'll take these four dollars and
they'll go buy securities in the open
market normally very safe and very
liquid securities liquid means it's very
easy to buy and sell those securities
and large quantities for example
government Treasuries is a liquid
security or liquid asset Pez dispensers
would not be a liquid asset if I bought
a billion dollars worth of Pez
dispensers it would be very hard for me
to set what would be very hard for me to
buy a billion dollars worth and would be
even probably even harder for me to sell
a billion dollars worth in in any short
or medium timeframe so the central bank
goes out and let's say they go and buy
one liquid security for $4 so this is
the security right over here and the
person that they bought the security
from decides to deposit it in a bank
they could either directly deposit in a
bank or they could use that money that
they got from selling their security to
buy things and the person they bought
things from could deposit in a bank but
one way or another we can imagine that
it all gets deposited in the bank so
this is our private bank I'll call this
private bank number one so now all of
these dollars are transferred they are
all transferred to private bank private
bank number one and they are no longer
the Federal Reserve or the central bank
in the general case is no longer in
possession of them they've been
transferred right over here and I want
to cross these out just so that we can
make we can keep track of things now
when they deposit it in private bank
number one they said well I need three
three of these dollars on demand and I
want to write checks against them so
they put three of these dollars in a
checking account they write three of
these dollars in a checking account so
checks up to so write write checks
checks up to up to three dollars
and so they can get a little bit more
interest in the banks willing to give a
little bit more interest on an on a
savings account because they don't have
to keep the reserves they put $1 into a
savings account $1 into a savings
account and they cannot write checks
against that savings account now there
are special circumstances now but for
simplicity let's just make let's just
say that they cannot write checks there
are some that have restricted check
writing and things like that now so this
this Bank says okay well this dollar I
don't have to have even have any
reserves against it I could loan out
this dollar and the person they lend it
to let's say that they immediately go
and deposit it into another bank so they
immediately go and deposit this in
private bank I'll call this private bank
too
so it's no longer in private bank 1 let
me draw a private bank to private bank 2
is right over here private bank number 2
and they deposit it into a savings
account in private bank number 2 and
let's say all of this out of all of this
the bank says well this is it on this is
a demand deposit I have to keep some
reserves this is a fractional reserve
system but I can lend out in the u.s. I
could lend out up to 90% of this let me
be this banks a little bit more
conservative they only lend out
two-thirds of this so they lend out two
out of these three dollars now let's say
that a person they lend it to also
happens to deposit it in private bank
number two just coincidentally so these
these two also end up in private bank
number two and so they are no longer
they are no longer in private bank
private bank number one all this person
can still write checks up to $3 and now
here in private bank number two and
let's say these are deposited in a
checking account these are deposited
right over here in a checking account
now private bank number two it can do a
couple of things in this checking
account it has to keep some reserves
let's say it's even more conservative it
only decides to lend out half of this
even though it could lend out 90% and so
it lends out it lends out one of these
dollars and the person that they lend it
to just takes that dollar and they put
it in their wallet so they just put it
in their wallet and they could also lend
out this entire savings and let's just
say that the person that they lend that
one dollar and savings to also puts it
in their wallet
also puts it in their wallet and notice
the original $4 are still there one two
three four now and just to be clear this
person right over here can write checks
up to three dollars and this person
right over here could write checks write
checks let me do that same check
checking account color they can write
write checks up to two dollars up to two
dollars now let's think about the
different forms of money there are here
well we could think of money in a very
very narrow way which is just what did
the central bank print or create
electronically as electronic reserves of
its member account of member banks but
for simplicity here you can just think
about the physical currency that it
printed its base money and so that an
often term it's just referred to as base
base money and in the US and other
countries it's often the same thing as
m0 there's slight differences from
country to country and in this example
as soon as they printed it put into
circulation that was four dollars we had
four dollars of base money and that's
obvious because as soon as you they
printed this and they bought the
security with it and it was in
circulation that four dollars could be
used to buy things it could be used to
facilitate transactions now that clearly
isn't all of the stuff that can be used
as money in this little universe we
created this guy you have the four
dollars but these people can also write
checks right over here and so we can
have a slightly broader definition of
money and over here we will call it m1
and here there's a couple of ways you
could think about it you could think
about it is all of the currency that's
in people's pockets plus all of the
cheque writing capabilities so if you
view it that way it would be this two
dollars plus five dollars of check
writing capabilities right over here so
you could have two dollars of physical
currency that's in people's wallets not
in bank reserves plus plus the five
dollars of check writing capability plus
five dollars of check writing capability
which would give you seven dollars
another way you could view it you could
view it as M 0 M 0 plus checkable
deposits plus I'll just write checks
here plus check while right checkable
deposits but if you do that you are now
double counting because some of the m0
is reserves in the checkable deposits
where AG you should say some of the
checkable deposits is held as reserves
for m0 so then you would have to
subtract out the bank reserves the
reserves reserves and so then you would
get $4 because we don't want to double
count these right over here you would
get m0 is $4 and I want to do that in
white M 0 M 0 is 4 dollars the checkable
deposits is is $5 is let me do that in
the pink plus the $5 and then you would
want to subtract out the reserves and
the reserves here there are two dollars
of the reserves so - two dollars - two
dollars and you would get yourself back
to get yourself back to the $7 and the
whole point of this is so you're not
double counting something you're not
double counting this right over here as
part of checkable deposits and part of
and part of the the m0 you're not you're
not using this twice so it's not part of
the basement it's it is both base money
and checkable deposits and we don't want
to count it twice so and the simplest
way to think about is well what can be
used in this broader definition to
facilitate transactions these two
dollars in people's pockets and this
ability to write up to five dollars of
cheques so that's this view right over
here and if we want to get an even
broader than that we can get to
something called m2 and here we could
say okay what's immediately usable as to
facilitate a transaction right now so
that would be our m1 so that would be
our seven dollars of m1 plus things that
can be easily converted to m1 so for
example these savings accounts can be
easily converted to checking accounts
they don't might only take a couple of
days there might be some restrictions
but it can be converted when it gets
converted it will change the bank's
reserve requirements a little bit but it
will allow if this person converts it
they will have the ability to write more
checks so m2 includes
m1 plus things that are very easy to
convert to m1 and so they'll include
things like savings accounts savings
accounts money market accounts which I
won't go into detail here but they are
really kind of similar that you get
slightly higher interest but they're
restrictions on your ability to
access it but it's not too hard to turn
it into checking accounts and things
like and small dollar value time deposit
CD accounts but for the sake of
simplicity in this example it would be
the saving accounts so it would be our
seven dollars of m1 seven dollars of m1
plus the two dollars of savings accounts
right over here plus the two dollars of
savings accounts so this is just to give
you a picture when someone talks about
the money supply you really have to say
well what are you talking about the the
most typical one is that you're really
talking about m1 because this is the
stuff that's directly usable to
facilitate transactions things like the
ability to write a check or dollar bills
in someone's wallet but they might be
talking about base money m0 narrow money
all ways of referring to the same thing
especially in the United States or they
might be referring to something even
broader and there are broader
definitions even than m2 although m3
they've stopped reporting about it but
m3 would have things that are a little
bit further from being true money from
being a checking account but they are
already fairly liquid and so they'll
include other types of assets but the
Fed has stopped reporting this in the in
the recent past so these are the ones
that are typically referred to